chào các bạn video này sẽ hướng dẫn các
bạn các cái thao tác cơ bản khi chúng ta
bắt đầu soạn thả một cái văn bản thì
thao tác đầu tiên là chúng ta phải đặt
tên văn
bản trước khi xá thảo lưu ý cái đó và để
đặt tên văn bản thì chúng ta có hai
cách cách
một Chúng ta khởi động
guộc nhắp đôi vào biểu tượng
guộc chọn blend
document Sau đó chúng ta tiến hành đặt
tên văn bản này bằng cách chọn x hoặc
nhấn Ctrl s hoặc vào file chọn save hoặc
save add sau đó chọn tiếp là
brow và chúng ta sẽ chọn cái ổ đĩa để
lưu tài liệu của mình đó là ổ đĩa D lưu
ý chúng ta không chọn đĩa C Nha đĩa C là
đĩa hệ thống tức là đĩa lưu hệ điều hành
và các ứng dụng chúng ta lưu dữ liệu của
chúng ta thì chúng ta chọn đĩa D và nếu
có cái folder rồi thì chúng ta sẽ mở
folder đó ra để đặt tên ví dụ cần lưu
trong folder hợp đồng thì nhấp đôi vào
hợp đồng và tiến hành đặt tên Còn nếu
chúng ta cần tạo mới một folder ngay
trong ổ đĩa D này thì chúng ta nhắp phải
vào vị trí trống trong cái hội thoại CS
chúng ta chọn new và chọn
[âm nhạc]
folder và chúng ta đặt tên folder ví dụ
chúng ta đặt tên là tin học văn phòng và
nhấn enter nhấn enter tiếp để mở folder
đó ra Và bây giờ chúng ta đặt tên của
văn bản chúng ta có thể gõ by
2 và sau đó chúng ta chọn nút x để lưu
và thao tác đó là thao tác chúng ta đặt
tên Văn bản à chúng ta có được cái file
là bài 2 đó là cách thứ nhất Cách thứ
hai là chúng ta mở cái
folder chúng ta cần đặt cái tài liệu vào
ví dụ như chúng ta mở folder là tin học
văn phòng Chúng ta cần đặt cái từ liệu ở
cái folder này thì chúng ta nhấp phải
vào vị trí trống chọn new và lưu ý không
phải là chọn folder nữa
vì chúng ta cần tạo tài liệu tạo file
Word cho nên chúng ta chọn là Microsoft
Word
document và chúng ta đặt tên là bài 3 ví
dụ
vậy và chúng ta nhấn enter để kết thúc
việc đặt tên nhấn enter nữa để mở file
ra Và bây giờ chúng ta có được cái file
bài 3 đây đó là hai cách Tuy nhiên
thì chúng ta nên làm theo cách thứ hai
vì Cách thứ hai á là đảm bảo rằng là cái
file của chúng ta ví dụ file B3 này này
nó lưu vào đúng cái folder mà chúng ta
đã chỉ định ở đây còn làm theo cách một
thì có thể chúng ta lưu nhầm vào đĩa C
sau này chúng ta rất khó tìm kiếm đấy
lưu ý chúng ta nên dùng cách hai
nhá đó là hao tác thứ nhất đặt tên Văn
bản hao tác thứ hai là sử dụng tiếng
Việt
Việt để gõ được tiềng Việt thì chúng ta
trình dùng trình hỗ trợ tiếng Việt và
trình đó là trình unik đấy phổ biến và
bây giờ á là khi chúng ta bắt đầu soàn
thảo thì chúng ta ra chuột xuống Thanh
tác ngũ dưới này chúng ta kiểm tra xem
unik này đã bật chưa Nếu chưa bật thì
chúng ta hay là nó chưa khởi động thì
chúng ta phải thu nhỏ màn hình
của ra ngoài desktop tìm đến biểu tượng
unik ví dụ đây chúng ta nhắp đôi chuột
vào để khởi động nó đấy và khi khởi động
nó thì chúng ta lưu ý chúng ta chọn mở
rộng và chúng ta lưu ý phải chọn mục này
này khởi động cùng Window có nghĩa là
cái trình này á nó sẽ tự động khởi động
khi chúng ta bật máy lên và nếu chúng ta
đã chọn mục này này rồi thì chúng ta
không cần quan tâm là khởi động nó nữa
nha Chúng ta chỉ việc là và vào soàn
thảo văn bản chúng ta kiểm tra xem nó
đang ở chế độ tiếng Anh hay là tiếng
Việt mà thôi chúng ta nhắp chuột để
chúng ta chuyển đổi qua lại được chưa và
Như vậy chúng ta gõ tiếng
Việt nội dung thứ ba đó là Cập nhật lại
nội dung văn bản à Có nghĩa là cái gì có
nghĩa là trong quá trình chúng ta soạn
thảo cái văn bản thì chúng ta có một vài
bạn hoặc là à những người mà mới học
guộc mới làm việc với thì chúng ta gõ
hết nội dung văn bản xong chúng ta mới
lưu thậm chí khi chúng ta chọn Câ để
chúng ta đóng tài liệu lại thì chúng ta
mới lưu cách làm đó là sai vì chúng ta
phải cập nhật thường xuyên cái nội dung
mà mình vừa thực hiện để đảm bảo rằng
cái tài liệu của mình là luôn luôn được
cập nhật nha Còn nếu chúng ta mà không
thực hiện Chúng ta gõ 5 trang 10 trang
thậm chí 20 trang rồi sau đó chúng ta
mới chọn lưu thì trong quá trình gõ đến
trang thứ 17 18 có thể có sự cố gì đấy
thì nó mất toàn bộ cái văn bản cho nên
chúng ta phải cập nhật thường xuyên và
cứ khoảng 10 đến 20 dòng hoặc 30 dòng
chúng ta nhấn Ctrl s một lần hoặc là
chúng ta Ừ thực hiện một thao tác nào đó
xong chúng ta cần lưu ngay thì chúng ta
phải nhấn Ctrl S rồi lưu ý cái
đó và nội dung thứ tư Đó là một số tổ
hợp phím cơ bản khi chúng ta làm việc
với với guộc thì tổ hợp phím thứ nhất là
tổ phím Ctrl F4 tổ phím này cho phép
chúng ta đóng cái tài liệu lại hay là
đóng văn bản lại thì tổ phím này nó
tương đương với cái câu lệnh này này nó
tương đương với câu lệnh là chúng ta vào
thẻ file nha Chúng ta chọn close đây nó
tương đương V câu lệnh này là đóng tài
liệu Tộ phím tiếp theo là An F4 tổ phím
này là thoát khỏi ruộc
thay vì chúng ta chọn cl ở đây
đấy tổ phím tiếp theo là Ctrl O là chúng
ta mở văn bản đã có Tức là cái tài liệu
đã có trong đĩa mình rồi mình muốn mở ra
thì mình nhấn Ctrl o Thay vì mình vào
file chọn Open ở đây đây Open à Tiếp tục
tổ phím Ctrl n tạo mới một văn bản Tức
là chúng ta đang soạn thảo văn bản này
chúng ta muốn tạo một văn bản khác chúng
ta nhấn Ctrl N và sau đó là ba k thuật
tổ hợp phím mà dùng phổ biến đó là Ctrl
C Ctrl X và ctrl V thì Ctrl C là sao chp
Ctrl X là cắt và ctrl V là
dán Ví dụ như mình muốn là sao chép cái
chữ lại nội dung văn bản này n thì thao
tác đầu tiên chúng ta
chọn cái cụm từ đó hoặc đối tượng đó
Nhấn Ctrl C để copy chúng ta muốn đặt ở
một vị trí nào đó trong văn bản thì
chúng ta đặt không trỏ xuống chúng ta
nhấn ctrl V để sao chép như vậy là đoạn
văn này nội dung văn bản được chép xuống
dưới dướ này
Đấy và tổ hợp phím là Ctrl X là cắt có
nghĩa là gì có nghĩa là chúng ta di
chuyển cái đối tượng hoặc là di chuyển
động văn ví dụ như là muốn di chuyển cái
à
Ctrl F4 và an4 này thì chúng ta quét
chọn Nhấn Ctrl x à và xuống dưới cùng
này chúng ta đặt trỏ vào vị trí Cần cần
đặt cái đoạn văn đó và chúng ta nhấn
ctrl V Đó là các cái thao tác cơ
bản các cái tổ hợp phím cơ bản khi chúng
ta làm việc với với gu và video này là
kết thúc Xin chào các bạn